[Musik]
denk ich an österreich unbedacht so
sticht mir diese zu krawatten welt ach
so säuerlich in der nase denn am wiener
opernball träumen gar viele das süße
märchen von der monarchie
das ist im menschen drin etwas eine
liebe zu märchen und dieser opernball
hat kattas nicht mehr er hat dadurch
dass der fraktion ist wenn sie den
abschaffen
ich war immer dagegen weiter fragt wagen
der bringt so eine
das ist eine homogene gesellschaft ja
prinz und prinzessin jetzt nicht so sehr
die monarchie als überhaupt die
vorstellung alle kinder märchen sind
policen und prinzessin das ist es ist
nichts anderes ist einer dieser
märchenprinzen richard lugner jedes jahr
sorgte am opernball für einen skandal
ich würde sagen die österreichische
seele es gemütlicher wir sind auch ein
gemütliches volk wir leben noch von
unserer tradition dass wir ein großes
kaiserreich war und in dieser tradition
führt eher mau sie spart oder ruby an
den ball
vor zwei jahren erschien er mit
berlusconis edel prostituierten taktlos
im dreivierteltakt alles walzer oder was
wie ticken unsere nachbarn
ich mache mich auf die suche nach der
österreichischen seele
[Musik]
mein film beginnt im bahnhof zürich
profil wochenzeitung wochenmagazin
nicht mal am größten chaos gehalte in
österreichische zeitungen
kein wunder haben wir vom nachbarn
keinen schimmer mit meinem kameramann
reise ich nach wien
auf der suche nach dem was übrig
geblieben ist von den habsburgern
ich kenne sie kaum diese nachbarn obwohl
sie die gleiche sprache sprechen die
gleichen alpen haben und ihn etwa gleich
groß sind wie wir schweizer und
eigentlich sind sie mir gar nicht so
unsympathisch wenn da nur nicht diese
grässliche kaiserschmarrn wäre
[Musik]
wir fahren über die grenze ins
vorarlbergischen das erste
österreichische bundesland heißt auch
kanton übrig
mit dem rennen mit und was sind das für
leute die die vorarlberg sind das
wirklich höchst sind sie aber gehört
vorarlberg wollte vor 90 jahren die
eidgenossenschaft beitreten
die anschluss erfolgte nicht obwohl zwei
drittel der vorarlberger dafür stimmten
der schweizerische bundesrat lehnt er ab
es hätte die deutschschweiz gegenüber
den anderen landesteilen noch stärker
gemacht
doch was hat vorarlberg mit wien zu tun
eigentlich noch heute nichts
mittlerweile bin ich eine zug stunde
hinter salzburg beim österreichischen
schriftsteller christoph ransmayr habe
ich einen text gefunden
die ersten jahre der ewigkeit
[Musik]
hauptstadt
was man weiß ich nicht aber ziemlich im
zentrum von österreich leicht
[Musik]
altstadt zählt 700 seelen dorf auf dem
friedhof sind es tausende
ein großes gedrängel friedrich von
anthony damm war hier der letzte
totengräber heute kommt der gelernte
handwerker ebenfalls einer besonderen
arbeit nach doch davon später
es ist die extreme es ist dieser schmale
platz der eingeklemmt ist zwischen der
steilen felswand und dem see
wir haben hier noch bedingungen wie an
einem mittelalterlichen friedhof und das
war ihre heimat kann man so zu sechs war
für sieben jahre meine heimat ich war
hier totengräber und habe die gräber
ausgehoben und wie war das das erste mal
als 19-jähriger totengräber hier ja es
war natürlich aufregend es ist einfach
dieses konfrontiert werden mit etwas
völlig neuartigen mit der vorstellung
wie wie sieht das aus was erwartet mich
und ich habe bis zum deckel des tages
gekommen ist so die särge hier werden
traditionell aus lärchenholz gefertigt
sie sind also sehr haltbar auch nach 20
30 jahren ist das sagt noch erhalten und
ich hab dann wirklich den sack
freigelegt und hat dann den deckel
geöffnet natürlich angst vor und es war
aber eigentlich dann dieser doch
vollständig skelettierte leichnam in den
sack hat so einen friedlichen eindruck
gemacht es war keineswegs dann ein bild
des schreckens oder des horrors sondern
vielmehr ein bild des friedens im
kleinen friedhof müssen zwei der drei
leichen ein grab teilen der totengräber
erhielt für seine arbeit keinen lohn
dafür kostenlos wohnung und werkstatt
was hat sie dann beseelt an diesem beruf
totengräber
es ist sicher dass ein element ist die
ganz einfache arbeitszufriedenheit
es ist ein beruf in dem sie schwer
körperlich arbeiten wo das ziel der
arbeit völlig gleis und die
sinnhaftigkeit nie in frage gestellt
wird es gibt einfach einen gilt einen
leichnam würdig zu bestatten
man schwitzt bei der arbeit und wenn
wirklich das werk getan ist wenn das
grab wieder zugeschüttet ist wenn die
grabeinfassung wieder perfekt versetzt
ist man steht am ende eines arbeitstages
spürt seinen körper und ist sich bewusst
dass man eine sinnvolle arbeit
vollbracht hat
[Musik]
die gebeine werden gesammelt und
sozusagen ein zweites mal bestattet
[Musik]
das bemalen der schädel war auch aufgabe
des totengräbers der ist sicher von mir
sie werden nämlich immer wieder
umgeschichtet und jeden des bergmanns
zeichen die werkzeuge das gezerre
schlägel und eisen als symbolische den
werthmanns beruf nicht ganz abwegig der
hang der österreicher zum morbiden ja so
interpretiert es ist jetzt natürlich von
für mich aus der innensicht nicht so
leicht zu sehen für mich hat das lied
sich etwas ganz selbstverständliches mir
ist dieses beinhaus dieser kammer so
vertraut dass er zu meiner
alltagswirklichkeit gehört und je in
hallstatt müssen selbst die toten noch
für den fremdenverkehr arbeiten
studenten lernen den denkmalschutz ihr
professor ist wurde einzige in
österreich der totengräber war der
totengräber hat ihn wie in die matura
nachgeholt architektur studiert und in
denkmalpflege doktoriert seit zehn
jahren ist friedrich dahm wieder zurück
in hallstatt als professor an der
restauratoren hochschule mit 400
studierenden herr professor wii
erscheint ihnen denn die österreichische
seele meine lieblings beschreibung ist
von ödön von horváth wo in den
geschichten aus dem wienerwald der
rittmeister die österreicher so
beschreibt fesch aber fein
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
und 7
ich komme in die steiermark weil ich von
einem einfachen bauern gehört habe der
vor 50 jahren eine besondere maschine
gebaut
[Musik]
hallo danke dass ich so gerne in der
maschine
der erfinder der maschine der bauer
franz gsellmann sein enkel hat das
vermächtnis von großvater übernommen
diese maschine immerfort in bewegung zu
halten würde die sogenannte weltmaschine
stehen bleiben
die welt würde stehen bleiben und somit
österreich untergehen
sein großvater habe eine sehr sehr große
begabung gehabt hier anders nicht
ausarbeiten
er wollte immer einen anderen beruf der
herren als bauer und das tor vernehmen
und mit 48 jahren hat er dann gesagt in
einen traum hat er die welt ist noch mal
gesehen und da dürfte sich das ganze zu
bewegen begonnen haben
mein großvater ist dann 1958 zur
weltausstellung nach brüssel gefahren
und hier weg und hat sich dort das
atomium angestaut und dieses atomium hat
das zum nachbauen begonnen und das
ersten teil für die band mal sehen wie
das dann auch in der mitte drinnen
diese kommen die hier rund um den käfig
das nicht bewegt mein großvater seine
maschine waren fast zehn jahre lang
eingeschlossen und er hat da dürfe sich
niemand sehen
da durften sie seine kinder sein vater
mich zählen seine frau nicht und das
lösen von diesem raum hat einmal
umgehängt und hier getragen
warum man die maschine weltmaschine
nannte bleibt sein geheimnis
die enkel erzählt mir noch dass der
schweizer bildhauer jean tinguely hier
war bevor der seine berühmten
beweglichen skulpturen schuf
exakt neben dem provinz bahnhof an dem
ich zur weltmaschine ausstieg rat hat
eine gigantische weltuntergangs maschine
täglich werden hier 50.000 hühner
angeliefert aufgehängt geschlachtet
die vier teilt vakuumiert
und ins ganze österreich ausgeliefert
[Musik]
ankunft wien westbahnhof meine erste
adresse liegt im ersten bezirk mich
erwartet ein sprachkünstler in höhere
etagen
[Musik]
so schön
handschuh ist schriftsteller und das was
ich nicht nur ein wiener unter einem
wiener vorstellt ich bin ein typischer
wiener also es ist nicht nur so dass ich
ein typischer wiener bin sondern ich
werde auch als solcher verwendet es gab
vor einiger zeit mal eine schallplatte
über wiener musik relativ von
pakistanischen und da haben sie mein
gesicht vorne darauf gedruckt werde
dieses gesicht eben so mit diesem trend
zu dem ich in der lage bin und typisch
wienerisch ist also das heißt mit dem
westen österreich hat mein gesicht
nichts zu tun was ist typisch wienerisch
naja dass das ist so wie laut augustinus
die zeit nicht jeder weiß was die zeit
ist aber wenn man ihn fragt was ist denn
betreut weiß man es schon nicht typisch
wienerisch es hat zunächst einmal eine
gewisse art sprachpflege und das
ironisch zu sagen also das verschlucken
das wesentlichen also gerne kommt so
nannten haben und auch eine
bevormundende arroganz bei einer
verzweiflung dient sozusagen eine art
dauerbrenner ist nicht also das
sogenannte ranzen das ist eine
spezifische wiener qualität und dass
franzen hat eben nicht nur mit dem
inhalt zu tun sondern das ist eine
tonart also es gibt menschen die ranzen
und wo sie eigentlich ganz optimistisch
und ihr sagen weil sie eben von sprache
land er sozusagen drin hängen
[Musik]
in einem seiner bücher habe ich gelesen
dass sich österreich von den anderen
europäern bloß durch eine urin farbige
limonade dem allen unterscheiden
ich bin ein gegner das selbstironie
während sich sich ständig an wände also
ich bin selbst ironisch auch gegenüber
der selbstironie weil selbstironie ein
zeichen einer gewissen schwäche ist
nicht ironie ist nicht immer ein zeichen
von stärke und widerwärtig ist die
ironie der mächtigen nicht die sich
darüber amüsieren wie sozusagen die
untergebenen strampeln und doch nie
wirklich hinauf kommen werden wo die
mächtigen schon sind aber selbstironie
hat so etwas von sich selbst nicht in
die kämpfe ein lassen und bevor man
gekämpft hat ist man als selbstironische
unter sieger also es ist eine routine
des triumphierenden aufgeben der
triumphierenden selbstaufgabe also
selbstironie ist eine schwäche die sich
als stärke kreiert und in manchen
situationen ist sie auch durchaus
angemessen also sie sternen über die
komik hinweg die man der not gehorchend
an den tag legt
franz schuh erscheint mir als
freundliche denkmaschine einer der
letzten schriftgelehrten die als
glänzende interpreten eigener texte
auftreten
[Musik]
die österreichische seele wie in einem
gedanken gefasst ist die also lassen sie
mich noch einmal erlauben sie mir bitte
es tut mir weh im herzen in einer
österreichischen seele
aber es gibt cafés treffe seele es schon
der formiert zitierte musik in dem
zitierten kaka nimmt erbitte und ich
muss sagen ich habe das nicht für sie
gelesen aber wenn ich mich so fragen mir
gegenübersitzt sehe denke ich mir lesens
diesmal das steht drinnen ist es immer
falsch ein kollektiv nach charakter
merkmalen einzeln dazu berührten
warum seit musil steht diese frage warum
naja weil jeder in diesen modernen leben
sieben bis acht oder 51 karat und von
diesen 25 charakteren mit charakter fünf
charakter 7 überhaupt nicht ernst
nach diesem besuch gilt wohl musils mann
ohne eigenschaften nochmals lesen und
mit dem unternehmen die österreichische
seele zu finden großartig scheitern
[Musik]
die straßenbahn ist nicht nur ein
wunderbares verkehrsmittel
da zieht auch wiens panoptikum an mir
vorüber
[Musik]
kärntner ring oper und steigen zum 1
wegen meiner sprache werde ich etwas
bemitleidet wegen meiner herkunft
beglückwünscht
beim thema eu
[Musik]
aber sonst hat das habe ich nichts
gebracht so finanzpolitisch geld ist weg
dem würde ich widersprechen viele gehört
wenn du einmal erlebt hast wie du
bestohlen wird und vom bekannte
einbrüche und alles wie brutal die frage
muss dir ehrlich sagen das war früher
sie sind hier aufgewachsen ich bin hier
geboren
warum sind sie dann nicht weg wenn es
jetzt schlecht ist
mehr hängen
jeder liebt seine decken
wenn sie besonders sondern ihre heimat
die geselligkeit ja die fröhlichkeit ja
was die menschen nicht jeder es ist
schon ein land die musik
[Musik]
dort werden immer sein und die zweite
strophe ich sehe wie sich wien geöffnet
hat die letzten jahre als multikulturell
und interessanter geworden ist irgendwie
menschen schon im zweiten bezirk
erfahren sie jetzt gleich durch und das
war ja das ehemalige ghetto von wien und
das beginnt jetzt gerade zu blühen
ohne sieben jahre in wien und extrem
viel italien letzten zehn jahre
ich sehe auch dass sich videos von
dieser land klagewege bewegt zu zum
zentrum vom neuen europa
durch mischen die leute machten
multikulturell und interessant
wie ich zum friedrich engels platz komme
spricht mich ein wiener an und sagt sie
suchen sicher dorfcafé zum weltuntergang
dann verzieht er sich in die nächste
straßenbahn und zeigt richtung bristol
bude ein dutzend burschen mit harter
schale grünen ihre weichen kern
[Musik]
natürlich haben sie ganz lustig nicht
nur wir ja bist du für die niederlage
vor 1 wie nova vida wird damit auch ein
bisschen die erste das ist und dann
echten weniger verstehen und dann nicht
wieder gehen einen haken es treffe
verstehen das stolz der käse war das
größte muss jeweils gegen saisonende
jetzt aber muss sich endlich diesen
kaiser finden diese ikone was diese
traurige republik und einer noch
trauriger regierung alles erdulden
musste ist jetzt endlich geschichte
österreich ist wieder monarchie im
hotelzimmer stoße ich auf eine
österreichische kurz sendung
altkreis
seine majestät robert heinrich der erste
kaiser von österreich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der schauspieler robert palfrader z
promis durch den kakao wiener schmäh in
vollendung
eigentlich haben sie keinen kaiser mehr
die österreicher verspotten ihn im
theater und müssen auf nichts verzichten
nicht auf den sport und nicht auf den
kaiser
offensichtlich haben sie schon was zum
trinken gegen ihn lief überhaupt hätten
besitzen nämlich als aufstand unsere
unserer lieblings opernsängerin dsds
sieht man muss er kam auf mich zu der
bitte der andere ja die
gesangsunterricht wofür schaden
man muss mit allen tricks arbeiten er
hat eine sehr junge frauen dann haben
wir da bildmaterial sich meist die
truppe stelle die erste dame ja sie wird
jetzt 22
alexander pereira ist ein
österreichischer musikdirektor jahre war
er am opernhaus zürich
[Musik]
ist das der schnee also etwas mehr oder
weniger bösartiges auf alle fälle etwas
das nicht ganz so ist wie es zu sein
scheint
der zeremonienmeister des kaisers nimmt
mich mit in die kapuzinergruft rudi
roubinek zeigt mir wo 12 kaiser und 19
kaiserinnen liegen allesamt habsburger
deren geschlecht sich von ihre stammburg
im heutigen kanton aargau er leitet die
dynastie herrschte überall europa
[Musik]
rudi roubinek schreibt die entzünden
dialoge seines theater kaisers wir sind
kaiser ist eine talkshow wie es
eigentlich viele gibt auf der welt
manchmal ist der talkmaster eine
wirkliche person manchmal ist eine
kunstfigur
wir kennen sicherheit dem etwa zum
beispiel und wir haben nach einer figur
gesucht die haltung österreichs ist und
die in österreich hoffentlich auch gut
ankommt und das ist eben der kaiser also
der kaiser ist eine fantasiefigur er
kokettiert natürlich mit der gewissen
geschichte österreich hat er viele
kaiser und manche man durchaus verrückt
verschwendungssüchtigen gierig
promiskuität druck süchtige et cetera
also ein bisserl ein wahrer kern ist
schon dabei
diese gruft wird besucht vom kaiser fans
und manch ein traum entzündet sich hier
unten
[Musik]
die österreichische seele ist kleiner
als sie sein möchte also wir beginnen ja
wir beginnen ja heuer 100 jahre erster
weltkrieg und durch diesen ersten
weltkrieg durch das ausgehende des
krieges ist österreicher auf einen rumpf
geschrumpft
also von einem ehemaligen 60 millionen
vielvölkerstaat der sich durch ganz
mittel und osteuropa erstreckt hat ist
es jetzt einfach erklären keine start
und so klein die menschen empfinden sich
als kleinzell ich aber sie werden gern
größer und das merkt man immer den
österreichern ob ihre kleinheit auf die
füße getreten wird dann pudeln sie sich
furchtbar
in der kapuzinergruft liegt auch die
letzte österreichische kaiserin zita
verbrachte viele jahre im
schweizerischen exil im bündnerland war
sie sozusagen meine nachbarin vor 25
jahren starb und durfte zurück nach
österreich
schöne leich hörte man ganz wien unter
tränen
[Musik]
wer bewerten lassen
zita die kaiserin von österreich
gekrönte königin von ungarn königin von
böhmen von dalmatien
blasien carolien galizien lotterien
höhepunkt des staatsbegräbnisses ist das
anklopfe ritual in der kapuzinergruft
[Musik]
ein sterblicher sündiger mensch so
kommen sie herein
sic transit gloria mundi so vergeht der
ruhm der welt
unser taxifahrer mustafa musste noch nie
an diese ausgefallene adresse narrenturm
pathologische anatomie
[Musik]
doch nicht da gibt's keine türen fahren
vor 230 jahren ließ kaiser josef die
narrenturm im wiener krankenhaus bauen
doktor winter erwartet mich ursprünglich
fünf etagen mit je 30 zellen für die
verrückten
mittlerweile habe ich schon viel
morbides angetroffen
doch diese sammlung übertrifft alles da
sind muss das sind wachs abgüsse da hat
man vom patienten also von dem
körperteil oder was man darstellen
wollte einen abdruck genommen
das war richtig so es ist eine
nachbildung also da ist nix dazu
erfunden oder weggelassen sondern da hat
man wirklich diesen abdrücken hat man
einst mit wachs schichten ausgegossen
und angemalt und möglichst naturgetreu
und was nutzt das heute an also diese
collagen sind für schüler und studenten
für für lehr führungen also kann man
habe ich auch ergreifen
die digitalen auch die garantierten ist
sie wäre es gibt eigentlich nichts was
es nicht gibt was es heute also die
meisten gern hätten diese berufe sehen
gibt es auch noch in der realität auch
so dr winter lagert 50.000
österreichische körperteile
das sind meistens totgeburten oder
kuriere achtet geburt verstorben
und das sind eben eben das sind das sind
dies indem man die ezb am brustkorb
gewachsen da hinten da sind wirklich die
körper miteinander verwachsen
das ist eine andere form der fehlbildung
dass es einen verlust da ist kein gehirn
ausgebildet worden
dabei ist das ist durch einen
folsäuremangel während der
schwangerschaft passiert dass folsäure
ist in der stadt ist nicht wichtig auch
die ernährung allgemein
das früher nachdem er das frühere ist
nicht gewusst hat sind als solche
ich bin immer wesentlich häufiger
gewesen als heute
und das ist fakt ist aus
unterschiedlichen gründen also meistens
ist es durch eine mangelernährung dass
das wird das nicht zu wenig vitamin d
aufgenommen wird auch zu wenig
sonnenlicht dass man braucht dass das
vitamin d das muss ich wieder aktiviert
werden im körper hast und das sorgt dann
eben dafür dass die knochen aus herten
im großen ganzen und wenn ja wie viel
tiefer 19 und 25 jahren sonst schwestern
das hier so typischen studien räume also
wir haben die die organe die sind
bewusst also die die frage beraten sind
nach veganen gegliedert das heißt da zum
beispiel präparat befinden
der vergessliche reporter und die gute
seele eines taxifahrers mustafa läuft
mir mit dem wechselgeld nach dem wesen
mensch wirklich näher
ja schon also das erklärt am besten aber
ich weiß nicht das ist der tod gehört
einfach dazu zum leben das ist ein teil
und da hat dem wird man sich bewusst
hier dringen dass einfach alles
vergänglich ist irgendwann steht jeder
es wird jeder irgendwann gar stirbt
das wird sich nicht verhindern lassen es
nicht nur keiner wahrhaben aber es ist
so das wird irgendwann trifft 7
und wann ist eigentlich ganz froh wenn
man hier rausgeht dass man diese ganzen
gang kennen alle nicht hat es geht auch
viel besuchen sollte jeder ausgeht und
sagen eigentlich sind sie ganz froh dass
sich und so gut geht
ein gutes ziel raus wegen waren nicht
schon mal da hinein
das sind alles herz präparate alle
kerzen
wenn sie sich jetzt auch so gut
auskennen in hessen können sie mir
sicher weiterhelfen
auf der suche nach dieser
österreichischen seele
wie praktisch dass die österreichische
seele
das ist schwer und besten im jetzt aus
dem café hause wiener kaffeehaus das
kommt dem schon sehr nahe
ein gewisses maß an gemütlichkeit und
das war es nicht zu schwer nimmt das ist
glaube ich die grundeigenschaft des
videos würden dann jammert über alles
aber in wirklichkeit ist es eben zu
schließen das glaube ich das trifft es
ganz gut was eben wieder einige noch
mehr exponate einige schädel
da aber noch mal die syphilis bank
schedler wir haben auch einzelne
verletzungen also das ist ein bisschen
skurril vielleicht ein unfall beim
kugelstoßen auch wieder ein winter ja
das ist oder aus kanada teilweise
verändert es aus dem aus der ganzen
monate kommune das könnte was aus dem
aus der monarchie gewesen seien das kann
ruhig könnte italien zum beispiel oder
aus tschechien untersuchungen also auf
jeden fall ein königlicher kugelstoß
unternehmen haben einen kaiserlich
königlichen oberstleutnant der pistor
durchgefallen ist er ist sogar die
kuchen noch
nun aber weg von den tod mühe in in den
dritten bezirk von wien
ich bin gast bei elisabeth spieler für
unsere unterhaltung über die wiener muss
sie noch etwas über meine sprache
loswerden
entsetzlich sei es dieses
schweizerdeutsch
doch die spieler setzte ihr taucht die
lieben nachbarn
es gibt nicht den
aber es gibt natürlich bestimmte gruppen
in wien um den dies sozusagen sauer
reagieren auf minderheiten auf ausländer
das gibt's natürlich überall aber auch
leider gottes in ganz europa hier ist
ein bisserl schmuddeliger also der
wiener ist sozusagen ein wadlbeißer ist
ein madl beißen müssen uns immer sein
warum besser ist gibt es in der schweiz
naja also der von hinten kommt deren
auch nichts mehr so frontal protestanten
gehen von vorneherein aber die termine
es ist nicht der beginn aber sozusagen
und das wienerische ist er kaum ist er
weg wird übrigen geschimpft man muss
also aufpassen dass man der letzte ist
der weg gehen die ganze fernseh nation
kennt elisabeth spieler die große kleine
mit dem wuschelkopf macht seit jahren
erfolgreich dokumentarfilme für den
österreichischen staat sender
ich bin nicht politisch korrekt ich will
das gar nicht sein
und da war ich auch der erst sein wenn
das langweilig ist dann muss man spuren
and wegs aufpassen ob das anstieg ist
oder nicht
also ich nicht weiß dass ich manchmal
höchst unanständig jahren ist es immer
wurst spieler ist im britischen exil
aufgewachsen vater spanienkämpfer mutter
kommunistin nach dem krieg kam die jüdin
zurück nach wien
[Musik]
nachkriegs österreich trägt gerne seine
opferrolle vor sich her
spira wollte aber immer etwas wissen
über die unselige mittäterschaft
spielers film über das tätowieren zeigt
einen unverbesserlichen ich wollte da
kommt schon diese ganzen hitler
devotionalien die sie da haben das heute
immer noch immer von trigema töne
elisabeth spieler und ihre cutterin
bearbeiten den film des tätowierten nazi
die chronistin dieses österreichischen
planeten spürt menschen auf die man
längst beim teufel glaubte
mit keinem wort weil sie dem dass sie
uns warum soll ich das erwähnen ich bin
ja da reportern ich weiß er ist nicht
intelligent genug um zu wissen warum ich
solche fragen stellt manchmal hören sie
ja den vorwurf sie würden die leute vor
wie das haben sie zuerst erzähle ich ihm
das und dann dann dann sagst ja das und
ist etwas dabei spielers liebe gehört
einsamen männern vom tätowierten nazi
bis zu den nackten auf der donauinsel
denn die einsamen männer hätten es ganz
gern wenn ihnen eine mama zu hören
die donauinsel ist der größte
volksgarten wiens dieser film wird immer
mal wiederholt für den garten und
erklärte dazu der kataster zur schule
oder zur hölle
es gilt für jeden menschen der in seinem
umfeld etwas verstehen schwer und der as
rom ac dc gehört dollar in den usa
wie hat die findung was die da aufnehmen
dies gab österreichs schönste muss warum
morgen wird er dann mit der kultur wie
hat sich das ist garten österreich egal
so bist du und wolf zur witterung und
verhindern so die richter
unitymedia dem opernball stahl richard
lugner die show back spricht alles von
ihm und nicht von der oper
[Musik]
er ist der umstrittenste unternehmer im
land vom einfach maurer zum baumeister
ganz österreich kennt ihn als mörtel und
das ist da unser parade baustelle
gewesen
[Musik]
da kann man auch hineinschauen
das minarett ist ein bisserl höher
geworden
das war mit einer 20 meter geplant
also lud auch moscheen
das war eigentlich jedes bauwerk wohl am
bekanntesten geworden sind es war der
größte erfolg in der geschichte der
firma lugner von der werbung her
der baumeister und die schlagzeilen dazu
flüstert mir lugner noch von mir aus
schimpfen sie über mich aber schreiben
sie bloß meinen namen richtig
der baulöwe als party tiger 1997 das ist
die welt und sie ist natürlich überall
geliftet und ich bin mit ihr im auto
voran
hier und da gibt es ja ein feldchen aber
es ist gut gemacht wird ich sei seit 20
jahren erscheint lugner am opernball
immer mit einem anderen busenwunder
diese parade musste die 81-jährige für
die ewigkeit festhalten
das ist nicht so verloren da habe ich
gesagt es ist eine tolle frau
da war eben die frage wie ist das
dekolleté so gehoben zu sehen und das
ist eben sie hat sich nackten dass
kleider nähen lassen und damit kommt das
dekolleté deutscher geltung ist die
ivana trump die war tolle frau hand und
auch unkompliziert das ist die große
chance die wahl sechs süchtig aber nicht
noch mehr sondern nach dem neuen frei
die väter akw ist auch eine tolle frau
gewesen
lugner mit einem orden der stadt wien
ist nur ein silbernes ehrenzeichen weil
ich einmal ohne baubewilligung gebaut
hat man mehr das goldene nicht verliehen
was kosten sie die open große teile ich
privat was kostet das
ich habe 120000 euro für einen namen ja
die gastgeber gegen die man frauen zeit
spreche ich nicht man muss auch cavalier
sein moped neuer wille mit einer
veritablen zickereien den obama kim
kardashian hollywood nebendarstellerin
mit dekolleté
doch zuvor hat der blödel der nation für
mich noch eine geschichtsstunde
arrangiert am eigenen leib wie mir
lugner die geburt der österreichischen
flacke demonstrieren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ein ritter bei lugner heißt er
selbstverständlich richie zog vor
jahrhunderten in die schlacht heldenhaft
starb er für österreich
blutüberströmt von oben bis unten
nur unter der bauchbinde blieb sein
gewand weiß rot weiß rot das ist die
geburt der österreichischen fahne vom
ritchie aus österreich ich bin nicht am
ziel mit meiner suche nach der
österreichischen seele aber am schluss
zwei seelen wohnen ach zu weinen dieser
kaiserschmarrn zum anderen der schnee
dieses feine schmunzeln über sich selbst
[Musik]